Key Technical Matters: How to Pitch.
The fact that you're amped is not something that needs to be pointed out to the "pitchee."
Related: Never use the word "pitchee."
In business, a pitch should not involve a pitching motion.
It should also not involve a batting motion.
At no point should you say, "Now bear with me here or please."
At no point should you ask if anyone is "picking up" what you're "putting down" ...
...unless someone is literally picking up objects that you're placing on a surface.
If your pitch is veering in the "spiel" territory,...
...remind yourself that you're not a carnival barker.
If your pitch is veering in the "claptrap" territory,...
...remind yourself that you're not in a screwball comedy from the 1930s.
If your pitch is veering in the "jibber jabber" territory,...
...wrap the pitch while backing out of the room quietly...
...because this partnership will probably not be flowering.
Leave your card anyway.